c'est bon mes parents se sont enfin là
c'est de dire face de bouc maintenant et
10 am stram gram trop bebar maman je
veux mourir tu es moi mes parents quand
même progressé en technologie est
maintenant et ça ce que c'est un bureau
à copier coller une fenêtre
maintenant que snapshot est sorti on
repart à zéro oui encore la tête de
chien comme toi oui le filtre snapshot
ok t'es sûr snapshot ras des cils jaune
oui ok maintenant que reste appuyé sur
ton visage et tu glisses sur la droite
[Musique]
voilà bisous way ma mère et sur snapfish
à toi en fait elle est absolument
partout
le pire c'est quand elle essaye de
poster un commentaire sur faisons sous
une photo de moi en vacances
elle laisse c'est bon j'ai retrouvé ton
carnet de santé et bien sûr tous mes
potes qui lui répondent pour bien me
[ __ ] la honte nous au moment
j'espère que tu vas passer des bonnes
vacances ça c'est un commentaire
facebook fasse prendre le pain ça n'a
rien à faire sur mon mur c'est un sms ça
et on part en commentaire honneur fois
elle m'a fait la meilleure
t'as pas répondu à mon commentaire les
commentaires de presse abou bassir
youtube c'est ta dernière vidéo moment
j'ai plus de dix mille commentaires sont
mes vidéos trop grande
c'est comme ça que tu traites tarayre
maman sur youtube des possibles quoi ma
mère m'a ajoutée sur tous les réseaux
sociaux il n'en manque pas un n'est pas
un réseau social je suis tranquille j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait elle elle peut
servir à tout moment comme ça avec
travail court commentaire la phantom
aller
m
[Musique]
pour cela sur une trame je te mettrai un
commentaire bon mes parents galèrent un
petit peu que la technologie mais c'est
rien à côté mes grands parents là on
atteint des sommets ces artistes etc et
coiffeurs fois ma grand mère a essayé de
me prendre en photo avec mon propre
téléphone moments cultes aux normes ami
jacques je vais le faire jeter ça va pas
marcher comme ça
le pire c'est qu'elle a réussi à prendre
la photo
comment t'as fait ça sans faire exprès
avec son nez sam raimi à s'y connaît
alors depuis peu elle a son propre
smartphone et ce qu'elle sait pas c'est
qu'elle appelle tout le temps en fait
style mammites et en vidéo là je parle à
une oreille qui comprend ça après des
heures de discussions avec une oreille
elle a enfin compris qu'elle était en
vidéo maintenant je parle d'un front
c'est un peu mieux alors ça c'est le
cadrage typique des lieux ça je me rends
compte que les vieux utilise pas la
technologie de la même manière que nous
dans le téléphone de ma grand mère
il y a le bridge on sait tous cotisés
pour lui offrir un téléphone à 500
balles elle peut jouer à des jeux en 3d
des jeux de stratégie ono quiz
téléchargez le gratuitement mais non et
jouent un jeu de cartes c'est quand je
vois les nouveaux trucs qui sortent par
exemple les écouteurs sans fil à 80
balle merci apple je me dis que ma
grand-mère et doit totalement tourné à
toi rien comprendre qu'elle se cherche
mes écouteurs il était bon c'est bon
c'est bon je m'en suis occupé mais ses
couteaux s'étaient cassé il ya plus de
films jeux achetés toi je te plus
d'écouteurs bon c'est fragile ces trucs
là et fils qui casse dommage tu as jeté
mes écouteurs ma vie 180 la grand mère
lui a fallu deux mois pour installer sa
box internet a été totalement paumées
c'était impossible pour elle entre les
prises téléphoniques les boks les cpl et
calmes ethernet tout ça était paumé je
peux pas m'empêcher d'avoir une pensée
de soutien pour ceux qui travaillent
dans les centres d'appels les services
après vente pour les box internet que
j'ai vu qu'ils appellent la croiser les
ja
le jeu vient voir que des jeunes on va
reprendre depuis le début est ce que
votre câble d'alimentation est bien
branché
oui bonjour en quoi puis bon je suis un
peu dur avec les vieux c'est vrai pour
une fois on peut on peut leur apprendre
quelque chose c'est une passation de
connaissances c'est beau quand même
merci d'être passé et merci de m'avoir
expliqué pour monter les face à sourire
mais ils ont quand même quelque chose
dont on rêve tous il 13 90% batterie il
est 16h chance oui si tu m'appeler plus
souvent même un sms peut-être que
j'aurai ma patrie asumani premier jeu
très bientôt
et la crue 90% à 16 heures il faut aller
le bridge abonne toi
[Musique]